guys I have a great idea for a prank
before Holt comes in I'm going to put
ink on the podium where he puts his
hands I don't think you'll fall for that
I did how I haven't even opened this yet
I guess it's unrelated Captain hold
hates pranks this is going to backfire
man G fine I'll tone it down I'll move
his Podium a foot to the left what he'll
be so angry okay five in five three
three one one all right I'll move it a
half inch fine it's your funeral oh my
God worst prank ever some stupid h's not
even going to notice good
morning
you guys it the
podium you're crazy how did you pull
this
[Music]
off oh hello guys guys guys check it out
H fell asleep in the break room so
I put his hand in a bowl of warm water
come on man that's the stupidest prank
ever uh know it's the smartest because
it involves biology I bet it worked
already let's go
check Hitchcock no he's drowning he's
drowning save him
man take it back Jake Great Prank I'm so
glad we could finally do this I know
Kylie says you're always stuck at the
preing
yeah speaking of this is work
sorry what's up pral Captain called he
needs everybody back there's a lead on
the nigh and Gale Strangler we're
looking for a white male 510 medium
build brown hair small scar on his right
cheek okay hism MO is he finds lonely
women with no friends poisons their food
and then guts them in his van it's
pretty gnarly last scene wearing a
salmon shirt gray Blazer and Witnesses
have said he has trouble fitting lettuce
in his mouth okay where are you
apparently has the world's smallest
penis and doesn't know how to use it hi
there I'm Jake falta Amy's boss that's
not true what are you doing here I am
here on a date who is now leaving worth
it have a great night your boss seems
really nice he's not my boss yes I am
I'm here I'm here I'm
here you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new copier 6 years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand The Importance of Being
punctual maybe you should just give up
and accept me for who I am no I will
break you right now while you were out
being tardy I was hard at work advising
a special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you Squad
dismissed goodbye
Diaz salute into a fanny wagle goodbye
boy this Snake Charmer goodbye
Jeffers that's a butt bump goodbye
Santiago double fist bump reverse
explosion into a Pete Town
strum all right that was terrible but
it's over now and I made it through
goodbye Leonard from Xerox what no no
the copy guy what's up G hiive it's
Queen G I'm bored at work so I'm going
to prank all my co-workers that sounds
like a bad idea for an already crappy
day fine sge I won't do it I will do it
so you can count this as my first prank
I guess unofficially hey can I talk to
the captain he's on the phone do you
want a coffee while you wait they made
me an extra one on accident oh sure
thank you
oh my God what is that cement you just
drank
cement guys check back in to see if she
dies you're not really going to die
probably okay look we're the police and
we're here to help you so shut your damn
mouth now tell us what he looked like I
only saw his back uh he had a blue
hoodie on woo we got a
lead you just drank
cement you just drank cement the
precinct will will not be shut down they
decided to shut down the 74 instead wait
I don't understand apparently the
community came to our Aid there was a
swell of online support orchestrated by
an organization called ginon I think you
mean
gazon I was behind the bar the whole
time another great Gina linetti entrance
I told you you can't be back here and I
told you I already am what did you do I
was live streaming a prank when Captain
Hol made his big speech about how you
did the right thing for the city I guess
people were moved they were like what
can we do to help and I said call the
Commissioner's Office the G hiive is
real I can't believe you did it Gina
you're a legend to the 99
St good morning boy it's
Halloween I'm surprised you didn't put
on a costume I was going to sir but then
I decided screw that jazz well I'm the
only one who ever dresses up no one ever
gets my costume and they make fun of me
so I'm done these people don't deserve
my dress up
gifts Charles seriously no costume what
the hell Charles where's your Halloween
spirit but you guys always make fun of
me I have never once insulted you in my
life especially Visa your appearance
yeah man we always love your costumes
remember last year when you came as that
person Andor thing yes I do remember sir
permission is spring to my car and get
my emergency costume does it matter if I
say no
[Music]
no bam bam
boom what the what why are you dressed
up you look like an idiot yeah what are
you supposed to be a sassy car mechanic
no come on he's clearly the rejected
Pop-Tarts mascot Harry poptart I am not
you know who I am Squad that's enough
you're making boil for bad on purpose
he's Elvis yes Elvis sto the Canadian
figure skater no I mean nothing like
that has ever happened to me and I've
done some pretty suspicious things in
the street hey hey hey there what are
you doing I'm just playing a prank on my
buddy sounds fun carry
on it was a very good prank I totally
thought I was going to
die whoa what's with the cast I sprayed
my wrist oh no what happened don't worry
about it I'm fine yeah gez Amy back off
leave the guy alone all right headle up
everybody bring it in so he wouldn't say
what happened which can only mean one
thing he's in a fight club no he did it
doing something he's embarrassed by like
smiling only question is how do you hurt
your arm smiling could be a sports
injury I sprained my wrist in college
playing field hockey men's field hockey
yeah it's much more violent than the
women's game we're not allowed to wear
anything that protects our breasts
attention everyone I can hear you
speculating about the ancient origin of
my injury from my office I tripped over
an uneven sidewalk I did not think it
was relevant to your jobs the jobs which
you should all be doing right now get to
work do you want to know how I actually
hurt my wrist yes I was hula hooping
Kevin and I attend a class for fitness
and for fun oh my god I've mastered all
the moves the pizza toss the tornado the
Scorpion the oopsy
doodle why are you telling me this
because no one will ever believe you no
no you sick son of a my only
question is which box is the belt in
well good luck figuring it out because
the clock is Tick Tick talking it's that
one no the dust pattern on top doesn't
match its neighbors you see Jake I'm
always going to be one step ahead of you
you've lost the ability to surprise me
you're just plain boring again weird
take on a very loving relationship and
it's midnight so I guess I'm an amazing
human SL genius yeah although you might
want to read the inscription on that
there belill why oh no what does it say
Amy Santiago will you marry
me
surprise